here are some of the absolute best Star
Wars ship Recreations people have come
up with in Starfield starting here with
this beautiful X-Wing from fudgy Brown
on Reddit this one is a y Wing from
somebody called schmeich I love what
they did to get the extra length like
what a creative build this of course is
a star destroyer this is a very good
attempt because you definitely can't
make something that actually looks like
a star destroyer this one's from slow
Pro on Reddit and like obviously the
shape is on point it's just the
thickness that they can't quite get but
like love some of the placement choices
here like it is as accurate as it
possibly can be this one is especially
nice from Supermarket decent 206 this is
a Razer Crest where they've actually
highlighted each of the pots so that you
can see exactly what they used and where
they got everything to make the razor
Crest and last but not least we've seen
several attempts here but this is I
think so far the absolute best
Millennium Falcon that anyone has
managed to make this is from someone
called imagination flat 3371 on the
Starfield subreddit and they just
absolutely killed this the details are
on point